[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online it's kind of a blur former
bachelorette Kaitlyn Bristowe fiancé
Shawn booth praised his ladylove on
Instagram for quote taking control of
their future revealing she had her eggs
frozen God are so good Ciara flaunted
her growing baby bump on Twitter while
rocking Calvin Klein undies and Mandy
Moore shared this hilarious throwback on
Friday - when she was 10 years old with
a crazy perm and braces
[Music]
Miley Cyrus won't stop getting tattoos
her father Billy Ray shared this pic of
his daughter's foot with some new ink in
his honor meanwhile Lena Dunham epicly
shut down internet trolls on the gram
who are obsessing over her recent weight
loss writing in part I feel I've made it
pretty clear over the years that I don't
give even the tiniest of what anyone
else feels about my body
[Music]
riot Kari took to social media to share
festive pics celebrating the holiday
with her twins Moroccan and Monroe and
later stepped out in West Hollywood with
boyfriend Bryan Tanaka both rocking
green on a more serious note flipper
flops Star Trek al Musa shared this
shocking before-and-after shot on
Instagram to show his body
transformation since fighting cancer he
captioned the pic in part I was a
skeleton the last three years were the
hardest of my life keep your head up and
don't quit
you